I started competing in pageants about a year and a half ago,
and one of the first things I heard from a makeup artist
was to use one of these
SK2 masks
before you put your makeup on,
before you put your moisturizer,
anything else on.
I only leave them on for about 15 minutes,
and my skin is super glowy for the whole rest of the day.
I save these for days where I really need my makeup to look amazing.
Like, it needs to look so smooth,
so good. I wake up,
I wash my face,
I don't put any moisturizer anything on.
I do one of these masks.
I like using these before photo shoots.
I like using these before,
like, public appearances where I'm gonna be, like,
speaking.
And I've even used them before competing on stage because it gives,
again, my face like this nice,
smooth below that'll look good even under harsh stage light.
Making sure your skin is moisturized is such an underrated tip
when applying makeup.
Like, no matter how much makeup you use,
no matter how expensive your makeup is,
it's not going to look good if your skin is dry.
Highly recommend grabbing a pack of these.